votée très forte sur les iphone 14 c'est
la première fois qu'apple nous mais de
lol ouais zone display c'est à dire que
votre écran va être allumées en
permanence même lorsque vous ne
l'utilisez pas ça devrait consommer pas
trop au niveau de la batterie parce que
vous avez une technologie sous une dalle
ltp au qui permet de faire varier le
nombre d'image que vous allez avoir par
seconde lorsque vous êtes sur les
oiseaux displayed vous tombez à une
image par seconde qui n'a pas consommé
énormément et comme derrière vous avez
une dalle oled à pixels noirs est un
pixel est un donc ça assez malin il ya
plein de smartphones qu'ils aient déjà
sous android mais c'est la première fois
que ça arrive ici chez apple j'ai pas ce
que vous en pensez dites le moi en bas
dans les commentaires on pourrait vous
tentez ou alors pas du tout et pour tout
savoir la critique je vous invite à
venir vous abonner